all right so we got these lighters cuz
it's
[Music]
lit hey yo what up I'm Travis Scott
these are my
[Music]
essentials oh Brown is a future Colors
of Life color of my heartbeat color of
natural being peace all things Brown
company Tranquility to me I guess it's
like a pool on earth from a design
standpoint like I said I just like to
share pieces of my brain and you know
kind of splatter it out as far as like
my ethos it just kind of Paints the
walls in my
universe my phone push made these
blackberries this one's like a gold one
I got it a while ago like years ago and
I just you know write in here write
scripts
[Music]
treatments
all right so we got these lighters
because it's lit you know what I'm
saying you never know when you got to
set off you know times might get
dark somebody might need a light and I'm
always there though I'm always the one
asking for a lighter I think I misplace
him to keep it a thousand cactus farms
is a re brand that we started and it's
amazing best gas on Earth at
peyote big red it's me and my dad's here
we go track meets remind me your track
meets you like challenge as a kid S on
forhe no I used to take the fall when it
used to be in fall and make girls out of
it though five no pun
intendent I mean I listen to my music on
different formats this is one of my main
playbacks T player I'm gu in Japan I
love tape players I love tapes I don't
know this might just be a personal thing
but just gets me through the day this is
raw the CDs are amazing I still buy CDs
you got in there right now um some
exclusive can't really talk about
it T3 my favorite camera having is for a
while take a lot of photos on it feels
like how I saw it but more like a movie
I guess what you draw to when do you
find yourself taking pictures of things
that make me happy I don't really take
photos on my iPhone so this get the job
done
[Music]
got to keep a mopy my phone's always
dying so somebody threw it in there just
cool though it's like a gauge on
it like a gas meter let you know how
serious it is yeah it tells you when
it's loaded and when you deplete it need
to charge it up I need some gas
93 well yes my bag for whenever I'm on
go my wallet oh wallets it's a blind
wallet Fair wallet a lighter wallet or
some just
pass I actually need a new one once I
finished like two weeks ago I think I
was in Rome or something oh no I greas
stamps start getting over stamped on
just like Tom me canno I guess classic
baseball hat yeah really this is just
like one of my favorite hats and you
know never know when I just might jump
off a cliff and land in some water and
might need
a
[Music]
hat I just keep a pair of sunglasses
nothing in particular from when I'm
faded keep out the Rays new
Utopia bright as
[Music]
here I mean these are like a special
headphones I made these specifically for
my ears listen back to music again on
these just a different playback these
are just designed different than your
normal joints I got normal ones now I
got these very special these things
Selzer the best Selzer in town
actually it's my favorite keep one on
Deck yeah got to keep a
colon cold give me
right midday action yeah I designed the
Canon we got a citrus flavor we have a
mango and a tropical fruit
punch thank you very
much man you with fruit punch
busting
[Music]
yo what up it's Travis Scot thank you GQ
these My Essentials peace
[Music]